keep Toffler has spent a lot of time
thinking about Steve Ben he is the
author of the book Bannon always the
rebel someone said the definitive
biography of Steven K Madden Keith great
to see it I would say that to show what
is you know Bannon weapons you wrote a
book about him right what's the point of
this
he doesn't do things presumably for no
reason I think that he was angry I think
that he at the time he said that it
could have been either July or right
after because I said it was it was soon
after a July story in the New York Times
so it didn't have to be while he was
still a staffer it might have come in
August right after he left the White
House I'm not sure either way he was
involved in these vicious internecine
struggles with in the White House right
I don't think there's necessarily a
point to this I think he might roll it
back if he could at this point I doubt
he will but I differ a little bit on the
results of this because I think that the
person you know you know what happened
here is that the President issued a
statement condemning an individual I've
covered the White House for 20 years
I've never seen that right maybe Osama
bin Laden you know other than that I've
never seen an official presidential
statement condemning it in an individual
vannin is not going to react well to
this he probably already has had some
trouble with Trump's flirtation with
dakka dakka deal maybe even a little bit
with the tax cut the problem for Trump
is this he has basically declared war on
Steve Bannon Steve Bannon likes Wars and
I think he's going to go for it he may
not come out in you know immediately
against Trump but little by little he
may end up picking apart Trump and the
problem for Trump is is that Bannon is
his conduit to the base his best conduit
to the base if he loses Bandhan he
cannot afford to lose a lot on the base
he only won that he may think he won the
popular vote but he did it the base is
what elected him and he and he needs
banner to support of that do you think
that Trump voters trust Steve Bannon
more than they trust Donald Trump no I'm
not saying that although O'Bannon is a
rock star among the populace voters that
that elected from what I'm saying is
that if Bannon does even a little damage
to Trump which he could do let's say
Trump wins the war if there is a war
against Bannon
if Bannon is if Bannon damages them even
a little bit
Trump cannot afford that and Breitbart
news and and and and Bannon himself is
the most important conduit to the base
that Trump has other than Trump himself
let's be clear Trump is the best person
for that but look how many votes he won
by you know 60,000 votes turned in the
election he loses it if it's another
type of election like that and he's got
one of his premier spokesman and he's
also been a spokesman for Bannon
for many months against him then you
know Trump can have so I mean just since
you know his mind let me ask you the
question I asked Matt flap which is this
is clearly not an isolated occurrence of
him attacking Trump he's been doing this
or through in effect cut out she's been
doing this for months right what's the
point what you trying to get out of that
well I mean mostly he's been supportive
of Trump I mean he what the people that
he is angry with are the people around
Trump and you know Ivanka Trump right
Jared Kushner who he calls Jovanka he's
been doing that without severe penalty
for quite a while now now you know and
you can understand Trump being upset
that his son is being called treasonous
of course but I think that you know you
know what he's trying to do is
marginalize people within the White
House who have a more establishment
Republican agenda and keep Trump's ear
and and and and keep Trump focused on
the things that he was elected on not on
his face you know Trump its family over
everything Trump loves his family right
in terms of his personality and his
actual political beliefs he's actually a
lot closer to Steve venom than he is to
Ivanka Trump sure seems that way yeah
Keith Scott floor thank you thank you
very much Voice on this question